all right i'm here i literally was still
putting on my earpiece let's listen
i am here to deliver this message on
behalf of the entire white house
resignation the violence we saw
yesterday at our nation's capital was
appalling
reprehensible and antithetical to the
american way
and caused by trump we condemn it the
president and this administration
but he caused strongest possible terms
but it's his fault it is unacceptable
and those that broke the law should be
prosecuted to the fullest extent of the
law
and it's trump's fault i stood here at
this podium the day after a historic
church
burned amid violent riots and i said
this
the first amendment guarantees the right
of the people to peaceably assemble
what we saw last night in washington and
across the country was not that
end quote make no mistake what we saw
yesterday afternoon
was trump's fault of our capital
likewise was not that
we grieve for the loss of life and those
injured and we hold them in our prayers
and close to our hearts at this time
we thank our valiant law enforcement
officers who are true
american heroes what we saw yesterday
was a group of violent rioters
undermining
the legitimate first amendment rights of
the many thousands who came
to peacefully have their voices heard in
our nation's capital
this is cringe those who violently
besieged our capital
are the opposite of everything this
administration stands for she'll never
take questions right the core value
of our administration is the idea that
all citizens have the right
to live in safety peace and freedom
those who are working in this building
are working to ensure
an orderly transition of power now
as of when for america to unite to come
together to reject the violence that we
have seen
we are one american people under god
thank you very much
oh my god
what a joke what a joke
isn't that something isn't that
something
so listen i i was planning a stream
anyway for the bottom of the hour i
ended up rushing in
because it was announced that this this
was going to take place
um uh i have
i don't know that i've ever seen her
move more more quickly than that
so basically trump's been banned from
every social media platform at this
point
um he is responsible for
a riotous violent insurrection
he has denounced his own vice president
and
uh i mean just wow wow wow wow it's
the the cowardice that we are seeing
everywhere here is truly truly
unbelievable
um so we will get to i mean we just have
so much and this will be a good
opportunity
to kind of get get caught up on all of
this stuff but it it is that was that a
30 second no i mean i guess it was about
a 90-second press conference
i don't know um very very strange
and there are other things that i want
to keep covering live this
caught me off guard because we i was not
planning on going live
um until just a little bit later um
but that's okay i'll just sort of get
everything um
set up as as we are going here i did
want to keep an eye out on what's
happening on newsmax and i
i don't think you'll be surprised that
they're talking about election fraud
oh god their president led a violent
insurrection yesterday and they're
saying you know there were
irregularities in this
there we had some irregularities in this
election
um so that's what's going on um from the
standpoint
of newsmax and then i had an abc
feed that i wanted to pull up as well uh
i'm glad you're here because there's
just a lot to get caught up on
um okay here we have we had an abc feed
as well so we have a lot of different
things here that that we're going to be
monitoring and looking at but
arguably the most humiliating 36 hours
of the presidency
of uh donald trump yeah let's let's
actually do that
i'm gonna replay the press briefing
because it was so
short let's see how long it actually was
so it went from minus
358 to
minus 210 so basically an hour and 48
minutes
let's just look at it again okay
i am here to deliver this message on
behalf of the entire white house
let me be clear the violence we saw
yesterday at our nation's capital was
appalling
reprehensible and antithetical to the
american way
that's true we condemn it but remember
trump said at all
at 12 30 we're going to go to the
capitol down
pennsylvania avenue and then at one
they went to the capitol down
pennsylvania avenue
you understand right okay the president
in this administration
in the strongest possible terms they
condemn it but he caused it
it is unacceptable and those that broke
the law
should be prosecuted to the fullest
extent no doubt no doubt
i stood here at this podium the day
after a historic church
burned amid violent riots and i said
this
the first amendment guarantees the right
of the people to peaceably assemble
what we saw last night in washington and
across the country was not that
end quote okay make no mistake what we
saw yesterday afternoon
in the halls of our capital likewise was
not that
we grieve for the loss of life and those
injured
and we hold them in our prayers and
close to our hearts at this time
we thank our valiant law enforcement
officers who are true
american heroes yeah and and there are
still questions about why what happened
even happened the way it did but we'll
have to address that in a subsequent
period of time what we saw yesterday
was a group of violent rioters
undermining
the legitimate first amendment rights of
the many thousands who came
to peacefully see she's missing a word
what we saw yesterday was a group of
violent rioters
inspired by and rioting in defense
of this president's attempt to steal an
election he clearly lost
right it's there's a lot of words
missing here we have their voices heard
in our nation's capital those who
violently besieged our capital
are the opposite of everything this
administration stands for
the core value of our administration is
like what do you mean it's exactly what
the administration stands for
the idea that all citizens have the
right to live in safety
peace and freedom right and trump
incited people making it less safe
those who are working in this building
are working to ensure an orderly
transition of power
wow so by the way notice how now they've
slipped that in
it trump put out a statement in the
middle of the night through dan scovino
because trump was banned on twitter at
the time suspended on twitter
saying that even though he won he'll
still allow the transition
and now she's pretending the last two
months didn't happen and saying
listen everybody here is committed to a
peaceful transition of power what
as of when as of five minutes ago now it
is time
for america to unite to come together
to reject the violence that we have seen
we are one
american people under god and of course
it's been time for that for a long time
and the reason it hasn't happened is
because of her boss
so absolutely bonkers and so now
a minute and 42 seconds i think we
determined uh that was so
uh listen she is one of a lot of the
rats have abandoned the sinking ship
trump even denounced his own vice
president yesterday but kaylee
mcinanni appears to be uh committed to
going down with the ship and i don't
know what she has going on the back end
and what she anticipates i mean she may
already have a
some kind of consulting gig lined up or
who knows right what her personal
motivations are but she has decided
she's going down with the ship so we
have a lot to discuss
today i have clips i have images i have
memes songs
um will i address my goatee probably not
probably not um my girlfriend has asked
that i get rid of it
it's just a goof i'm so bored that i got
a haircut and just started
shaving in a goatee um
she she described it as pervy to be
honest
and and uh so that's but i'm trying to
keep it for a little bit and then i
think the plan is i'll get rid of this
part and just leave a handle bar for a
day
and maybe do one stream like that and
then
it'll we'll just go back to normal so
that's what's going on i'm not gonna
goatee material is probably exceeds the
scope of this
stream i mean the country is in crisis
we can't be talking about my goatee
but um uh
yeah okay good so we've got that and
we've got a lot of other
of other things going on real quick just
so i don't
fall behind i do want to say thanks
to the five new twitch subscribers that
just signed up
and also want to say thanks to a bunch
of people who signed up on my website
um elena saboot or cebu
uh kristen kiley
as well as harry guzman
um yes okay so the three of you which
puts us at eight and yes i'm glad to
open phone lines we have a very modest
goal of a hundred for today
uh but there's a lot of other things to
discuss here so let me go through my
agenda
um let me continue oh okay so earlier
this week i said
is it conceivable that we will get to 4
000 coronavirus deaths a day
and 4 4 100 coronavirus deaths yesterday
so it's it's an
uh unmitigated tragedy at this point in
time
as far as vaccination goes there have
now
been uh 5.48 million doses
first doses mostly first doses in the
united states some second doses now
these these numbers are just completely
pathetic i i don't know any other way to
say it
um we've now vaccinated about one just
looking roughly one point we've given a
first dose to like 1.6
of the population we were supposed to
have 100 million doses by the end of
2020
we ended up with not even 20 million so
five
four seven eight five seven eight
divided by 331
so we're at 1.65 percent mostly first
vaccinations so
it's completely it's huge it's
embarrassing and humiliating
and we'll have to see how joe biden um
scales that up okay so that's the
vaccination
discussion not much else to say as you
can see donald trump has not tweeted
i i believe so i don't know if donald
trump is unsuspended and the reason i
say that is the way these suspensions
work
these early stage suspensions before
they just
delete your account essentially is that
um
trump was suspended for 12 hours but he
has to remove the three tweets
and this this most recent tweet was a
tweet
actually you know what let's look at um
here it is we can actually look at
trump's deleted tweets
so the most recent one was basically
trump
saying the violence is justified these
are the things and events that
happen when a sacred landslide election
victory
is unceremoniously and viciously
stripped away from great patriots
who have been badly and unfairly treated
for so long go home with love and peace
remember this day forever
this tweet uh is one of the ones that
got donald trump suspended he's
essentially defending
the violence um the other tweet was this
video
in which trump says it's time to go home
but we love you and you're great people
and it was stolen and we had a landslide
win
so that was both inciting violence or
defending violence and also election
misinformation
and then earlier in the day this one
where mike donald trump turned on his
own vice president mike pence
mike pence didn't have the courage to do
what should have been done to protect
our country and our constitution
giving states a chance to certify etc
etc and those are disputed claims about
elections so
thanks to those three tweets you can see
two of them are missing here
and the third one down here donald trump
was suspended for 12 hours
i don't know if the reason trump hasn't
tweeted is because he never
actually removed them and you you don't
get your account back until you remove
them
or because he's just staying off of
twitter for the time being we don't know
the answer to that at this point in time
in terms of yesterday so a few different
things i've been tweeting about and i
appreciate everybody who's been engaging
on twitter
number one there is the idea that this
is not over
and my instinct is that that is
absolutely correct
the anti-defamation league has been
monitoring
very closely the plans of these
extremist rioters
and as you can see the adl finds that
extremists are celebrating what they
consider a huge success yesterday
and have turned to planning their next
attempted coup targeting inauguration
day
now security is dramatically being
scaled up in washington dc around the
capital and i have every every belief
that joe biden's inauguration
much like remember every for two months
they've been saying
this state it's over this state it's
over this state it's over
everything has happened to scheduled um
december 14 you know everything's been
happening as scheduled
but i have no doubt that it is likely
they are going to try more and that
there will be
more violence um i tweeted earlier
there's this woman
oh she deleted it oh my god she deleted
the tweet
oh wait a second did she be did she ban
me oh no way
she oh she blocked me
oh my god so brigitte gabriel
is a lunatic bomb throwing right winger
and she had put together a tweet which
now
is on a i guess i could log out uh it's
just such a let me see hold on
copy linked address and then i'll do
incognito and then we'll go to it this
should allow me to see it
there it is okay good so her her
blocking me is not helping
she there's this picture right so trump
flag
trump hat trump hat trump hat trump hat
trump sweatshirt trump hat you see all
that right
bridget gabriel says the man in the
yellow
has a communist hammer and sickle tattoo
on his hand now i can't even tell
whether that's true
but if it is you're sort of ignoring
some key elements of that
so i responded to her and also tweeted
fascinating analysis is there anything
we can deduce from the trump flags and
hats
and yesterday we jokingly said they're
not really going to blame antifa right
they're not really going to blame blm
they're not really going to blame
uh communists or socialists and that's
exactly
what they're doing and then later i even
posted this
is it possible that the red symbols that
i've circled
might tell us something about the
ideological origins of the writers
or are we simply left to make wild
guesses and it's interesting to focus on
what she claims
is here when you've got one two
three four five six i mean i mean come
on guys
i don't know it's really young what
might be the political ideology
of these individuals and hilariously in
the hour since i tweeted this bridget
gabriel has blocked me
blocked me apparently her feelings
supersede my facts
so that's that um and then what else did
i have
from twitter that i wanted to share with
you guys
um
[Music]
oh okay yeah this this appears to be the
moment where it started
and you can see this seems to be the
first approach to what
at this point was a perimeter around the
capital
and this was going on on all sides so
you know it started
at a lot of different places but this
this appears to be the beginning
and keep an eye on this guy right here
[Music]
so yelling they start kind of pushing in
on the on the barriers and then it goes
crazy
and then see this guy gets ready he
takes off his denim jacket
in preparation for something and then
flips his hat backwards and that's how
you know he's ready
okay and then it escalated from there
[Music]
and then you'll see it just there it is
there they go for the barriers
so this appears to be sort of like
ground zero as far as um
as as far as yesterday is concerned and
what else here um
oh oh yeah yeah yeah we also noticed
this the woman killed today in congress
was a devoted q anon supporter who
believed today this is yesterday
uh would mark the storm the day q and un
supporters hope trump will arrest and
execute his political opponents so very
very ugly stuff um
yeah so that's that um let me do
let me do a couple of there's just a lot
happening so let let me do a couple of
messages
and and that sort of thing i do want to
say thank you
to the 24 additional twitch subscribers
24
people just subbed and a few people
gifted subs
which i really appreciate bepper's
gifting some subs
and did david chadman give some subs not
this time but that's okay
you can never thank david chadman too
many times and then also on my website i
want to say thank you to
nicole newton who just signed up jessica
billhart
and rudiger schmidt who are new members
33
34 and 35 at joinedpakman.com
let me read a few super chats the tattoo
is from a video game
says nicholas canavey that may well be i
have no idea
the name of the fur hat oh yeah i don't
want to get into naming specific
there's been i'm not saying you're wrong
but
there's been so much like incorrect
doxxing and stuff like that i want to be
careful with that
are there any parallels as an
argentinian you see between peron
and trump just curious well populist
rhetoric tends to look very similar
over over history um and so there's no
there's no doubt about that
the hammer and sickle is from dishonored
i'm guessing that's a video game
david will the david pakman show heavy
stream schedule be compliant with epa
standards post january 20th or we'll be
back to drip drip flushing toilets 10 to
15 times etc
yeah you know the the epa is very much
concerned with heavy metals
and the heavy stream schedule i think is
being looked at in a very
similar way oh thanks to i'm sorry
thanks to sputnik
and bonnet bornai for the gifted subs as
well
twitter specifically stated that the
12-hour time limit
starts when the offending tweets are
removed okay so trump may not even have
removed those uh
those tweets yet arrest alex jones
his comments we don't know how this is
going to end but if they want to fight
they
better believe they have got one david
the hammer and sickle tattoo is a symbol
from a video game
the hammer and sickle tattoo is a symbol
from a video game
the tattoo is from the video game
dishonored okay i think it's very clear
that that tattoo
is from the video game dishonored i
think we can we can safely say that
um okay i have i have
will you guys indulge me in just one
song we have a little time
today and i i do have one new song as
many of you might have heard
um donald trump's former personal
attorney michael cohen
did a warning about our membership
specials and i have it here
on my song spreadsheet dj
physic put this together for us this is
a remix
of michael cohen warning me about the
membership specials okay take a listen
to this
i like this michael cohen has uh agreed
to plead guilty to eight different
counts hey david parkman it's michael
cohen here prison really sucks
as a result of this um membership coupon
[Music]
whoa michael cohen in prison thanks to
one of our discounts
[Music]
first and foremost i need to talk to you
about this borderline
illegal membership coupon that you have
going for this
streaming news program the david parkman
show right
here's the bottom line i know all about
illegality
here's the bottom line i know all about
illegalities
the charges against them could carry
prison time potentially three to five
years although you really just don't
know
i know all about illegalities to this um
streaming news program
parkman show you may want to think about
that twice
because i can tell you firsthand reason
really sucks
yep so that's a cautionary tale mike and
michael cohen taken down with one of our
brutal uh membership specials and he's
ending up in a place
i don't think any of us want to be and
of course that's a mashup it's fake it's
just a joke
um and uh he's out of prison anyway so
i don't know how far how far that got us
um
okay people are asking me about the rudy
giuliani
phone call i want to play that
i don't know what people are referring
to though so can someone tell me what is
the rudy giuliani phone call because i'd
love to listen to that with you guys
together i've just been so busy today
that i haven't
had a chance to do it myself where can
we find the rudy phone call
that everybody's talking about i don't
even know who the phone call is to
or anything like that maybe even if i
just
do a twitter search i could find it rudy
phone call
he called a random person and left a
voicemail oh let's see
rudy giuliani meant to call senator
tommy tuberville to ask him to object to
votes
but he left a voicemail on a different
phone we have the audio oh that is rich
that is rich oh here's the audi let's
let's this this is amazing
this is the first i'm hearing of it
let's listen to it
president's lawyer i'm calling you
because i want to discuss with you
how they're trying to rush this hearing
and how we
need you our republican friends to try
to just slow it down so we can
get these legislators to get more
information to you
and i know that we they re uh
convening at eight tonight oh so this
was a phone call made in in the interim
period when the riotous coup
shut down the count but
the only strategy we can follow is to
object
to numerous states and raise issues so
that we
get ourselves into tomorrow ideally
until the end of tomorrow
i know mcconnell is doing everything he
can to rush it
that's interesting because it's very
clear that they they they've been seeing
mitch mcconnell as the enemy in this
which is kind of a kick in the head
because it's one thing to oppose us it's
another thing not to give us a
fair opportunity to contest it which is
funny because
you know they've had 50 opportunities
courts have dismissed all of them
they want to try to get it down to three
only three states that we can test
whether
there are ten states that we can test
not three what a joke
so if you could object to every state
hey tuberville object to every state
even objective states trump won just
make this last a month
and along with a congressman get a
hearing for every state
i know we would delay you a lot but it
would give us the opportunity to get the
legislators
who are very very close to pulling their
votes can you imagine
close to pulling their vote give me a
break it was like
what was it 93 to 6 for arizona
after what mcconnell did today it
angered them because they have written
letters asking
if you guys adjourn and send them back
the questionable ones and they'll fix
them up
so this phone number i'm available on
all night
and it would be an honor to talk to you
thank you
wow and so that voicemail rudy giuliani
thought he was calling a senator
and um i guess he called the wrong
senator do we know which senator he
called let's see if it actually says
here
um
approximately 7 p.m called senator
tuberville want to discuss with you
the problem is he left his voicemail on
the voicemail of another senator who
shared it with the dispatch it's not
clear uh
who it was okay and wow that is just i
mean it's a comedy of errors
it's uh it's it's it's really something
else that's that's stunning
um big thank you to spudnik and others
who keep
just massive dumps of twitch subs are
coming in
an additional 37 just came in
putting us at 72 and i also want to say
thanks to folks if you're signing up on
my website
these memberships are accelerating so
much i don't even know that i can name
everybody but in person one two three
four five six seven eight nine ten
ten additional people just signed up on
my website which puts us at 82. i really
appreciate
it i don't want to uh gum up the stream
by by naming everybody but no i
absolutely
appreciate you okay so we're standing by
for some kind of an explanation from
capitol police
as to what happened yesterday now i i
think maybe it makes sense to address
this issue
of let me see if i can even find the
video
um capital police barriers
and video
let me see if like there's a particular
video i want
okay so there i don't i'm not taking a
position on this because i just don't
know the truth of this
there have been assertions made that
this video is evidence
that the capitol police were in on the
riotous insurrective coup
and that they welcomed the protesters in
and in the video i'm gonna play for you
here uh they
they sort of like move the barriers and
allow everybody in
i'm not ready to say that yet quite
frankly
because um you know there are sort of
crowd control realities
oh and people are saying it's debunked
there are crowd control realities
and at a certain point if there's four
officers and 200 people
they're going to break it down and they
may end up hurting
you or the crowd in so doing okay
so so i mean let's just look at this
real quick but people are saying it's
already been debunked
police are squabbling with protesters oh
there we go
i mean listen i i i don't think it would
be it would be cl there
you know there's no doubt that there
were trumpist police officers
there's no doubt that there were police
officers taking selfies with protesters
but the the general idea that the
capitol police were in on this
this video doesn't demonstrate it for me
and it would be irresponsible for me to
say
that that's what this video is evidence
of it is a common thing in crowd control
that when you lose the control of a
perimeter
uh and you and you don't have the
manpower
you retreat and so i i can't i i'm not
ready to say one thing or another i see
people are arguing
pointing out these police don't even
have riot gear how are they possibly
going to resist 200 people that are
forcing forcing their way in so
for me the problems are there should
have been way
you they should have been more prepared
for this and the question of why they
weren't more prepared
is really the question that i i want to
have answered law enforcement failed
yesterday
to say they were part of a plot to do
this
i can't say and i think we should be
very careful about making those
allegations
but they failed uh the rioters
overwhelmed them
um and uh the police clearly clearly
failed in this particular case
uh okay let me move on to a couple of
things so i wanted to review
tucker carlson's sort of like monologue
yesterday about the riots i have not
seen it yet
so if people want me to review that i'm
glad to do it
there's also a new report that trump is
once again considering a self-pardon
a new york times article about that i'll
do both i don't know if people have a
strong feeling about which they want to
look at first
as we wait for a possible statement from
the
capitol police do we want to do the
tucker monologue
about the riots or do we want to do the
trump
self-pardon
looks like self pardon all right let's
go to the self pardon first so
i now before people start telling me
a self pardon is illegal or a self
pardon is legal
i'm gonna get to that okay let's just
look at the article first
trump is said to have discussed
pardoning himself the discussions
occurred in recent weeks it was not
clear whether he has brought it up
since he incited supporters to march on
the capitol where some stormed the site
uh president trump has suggested to
aides he wants to pardon himself in the
final days of his presidency
according to two people with knowledge
of the discussions a move that would
mark one of the most extraordinary and
untested uses of presidential power in
american history
in several conversations since election
day mr trump has told advisers he's
considering giving himself a pardon
and in other instances asked whether he
should and what the effect would be on
him legally and politically
according to the two people it was not
clear whether he had broached the topic
since he incited a riot is the way i'm
calling it
mr trump has shown signs that his level
of interest in pardoning himself goes
beyond
idle musings he has long maintained he
has the power to con
to pardon himself and his polling of
aids views is typically a sign that he's
preparing to follow through on his aims
he has also become increasingly
convinced that his perceived enemies
will use the levers of law enforcement
to target him target him after he leaves
office
no president has pardoned himself so the
legitimacy of
prospective self clemency has never been
tested in the justice system
and legal scholars are divided about
whether the courts would recognize it
okay that's the bottom line so everybody
to all of the legal scholars in the chat
yes a pardon would only apply to federal
crimes that's absolutely true
but for everybody saying trump obviously
can't do it
or trump obviously can do it the point
is it's not
actually been tested it has not been
tested
and legal scholars are divided some of
the
arguments are are sort of semantic in
nature the idea
some people focus on the word grant a
president may
grant pardons and there's a linguistic
argument that grant
implies you do it to someone else okay
um but they agree this is the important
sentence
they agree a presidential self-pardon
could create a dangerous new
precedent for presidents to unilaterally
declare
they are above the law and to insulate
themselves from being held accountable
for any crimes they committed in office
this is really the crux
of uh of the of the implications
okay and then by the way still in the
picture is this
issue trump has considered a range of
pre-emptive pardons for family
including don jr eric trump and ivanka
for ivanka's husband senior white house
adviser jared kushner
and for close associates like the
president's personal lawyer
rudy giuliani the president has
expressed concerns to advisers that a
biden justice department
might investigate all of them so
um very very important stuff that is
going on
and uh now to you and i
going by the spirit of what it should
mean to pardon we
we recognize this idea is completely
idiotic a self pardon what on earth are
you talking about
but legally speaking legal experts are
divided and what's clear is trump is
very very scared there's absolutely no
doubt about that
a few other super chats after all this
if he's not as
impeached can he still run in 2024
absolutely
absolutely they weren't prepared because
they anticipated a mostly white
crowd the riot gear tear gas is limited
to non-whites plain and simple
yeah listen i mean i i know you're using
sort of more more
inflammatory language maybe than i would
but can
anyone deny that if it were thousands of
antifa
or thousands of blm or whatever
that it would have been handled
differently yeah how can anyone deny
that
how can anyone deny that that it would
not have gone the way it did yesterday
it's
inconceivable to me it is completely
inconceivable to me
facebook ceo mark zuckerberg said it is
banning trump indefinitely
and for at least until his presidential
term is over on the 20th yeah we're
covering that on tomorrow's show
the question i have is says karen how is
it possible to pardon someone without
them being convicted
yeah you can do a preemptive pardon that
is a thing
that is a thing now it would only be for
crimes committed up until the date of
the pardon you can't say i'm issuing a
preemptive pardon that will also go
if you commit a crime in 10 years my
pardon today covers it
that that you cannot do okay
uh all right one other thing oh let's
let's do tucker okay yeah let's go to
the tucker carlson video
this is um this is tucker carlson last
night
i've not listened to this yet this is
tucker
addressing all day you've been bombarded
with what went on yesterday
images of what has taken place in
washington too little time has been
spent thinking about why
anyone is trying to understand the
significance of what's going on right
now ought to watch the video
of the woman who was shot inside the u.s
capitol this afternoon
in the footage which we're not going to
show you because it's too upsetting but
you can find on the internet
the woman is standing in a hallway right
off the house floor at the center of the
capitol building
she appears to be in her 20s she's got
an american flag tied around her neck
the scene around her is chaotic people
are bumping into each other
yelling trying to get through the door
into the senate chamber
suddenly with no warning there is
gunfire you hear a shot and the woman
falls she's been hit with a bullet seems
like the neck could be the chest
apparently was fired by someone in law
enforcement
people in the hallway scream the camera
closes in
on the woman's face she looks stunned
she is staring straight ahead unblinking
is tucker turning that woman into a
martyr
is that the gist of this eyes you can
see that she knows
she's about to die which in the end she
did the woman died a couple of hours ago
at a local hospital
so what can we learn from this right
well so
i'm i don't know what lessons he's about
to give us but if you ask me
what can we learn what we can learn is
that
every one of us being called alarmist on
uh
november 9th 2016
we were probably not sounding the alarm
enough
you had obviously almost all of the
right saying
you're too worried about what's going to
happen under trump and remember that
there were even these people
on the left and again to say that
they're on the left
is weird to me because they're not doing
anything that i recognize as
progressivism but
there were even people on the left
saying hillary is so
far right that there's no difference
between hillary and trump
would we have the supreme court we have
today were it hillary instead of trump
come on would hillary clinton have
incited a riotous insurrection that led
to death and injury
um and destruction of property at the
capitol had she lost
would hillary have waged a two-month war
claiming that
it was rigged would i mean come you know
so
so it's not just uh there what we learn
is all of our worst fears about what
donald trump might do have come
true and the culmination of that was
yesterday that's my lesson
okay let's see what tucker's lesson is
it's not enough to call it a tragedy
imagine for a second getting the call
and learning that was your daughter
the last time you said hold on a second
does tucker do these rants
when we have you know all of the police
deaths that we've had does tucker say
the focus should be imagine getting a
call that your loved one has died is
that his focus
because i've not seen that be be his
focus in those cases
spoke to her she was heading to
washington for a political rally
now she's dead well right but you're
skipping over the fact that
oh my god that's like saying hey you
know what i went to the ribbon cutting
at the new bakery and then i'm dead
well but hold on hold the what did you
do in the in the interim
what did you and it's a tragedy that
anybody got hurt it's a tragedy that
anybody died
these are people committing crimes you
understand
um she's wow
you'll never talk to her again seriously
imagine that
if you have children it will put you in
the right frame of mind
that's what we're watching and we may be
watching a lot more
of it in the coming days political right
but that's because they plan to keep
rioting
this is bizarre begets political
violence that is
always true it is an iron law it never
changes and we have to be against that
no matter who commits the violence or
under what pretext
but is he okay self-interested
demagogues assure us the violence is
justified
or necessary as they have been assuring
us lying to us
for the past six months we have a duty
to oppose
six m see six months is weird because
this is very different
you know one of the things that i think
is being ignored
is you know you've got these false
equivalencies being drawn where you have
a group that says well violence by all
protesters is bad and you might end up
getting hurt and that's violence by the
george floyd protesters and that's
violence by these rioters or whatever
the case may be
one of the things that we also have to
remember is that this entire
insurrection was number one
based on an imaginary set of facts
it was based on the non-existent theft
of an election
and it was fomented by the president so
to even compare this
to what we saw over the summer aside
from
tactics numbers police reaction
the fundamentals he's saying anybody
doing violence and anybody advocating
for violence
i'm against i'm against all violence as
well but
they're they're ignoring the fact that
this was a trump
incited coup attempt based on a
non-existent theft of an election
wow all of this not simply because
political violence kills other people's
children
which it does right but because in the
end it doesn't work
no good person will live a happier life
because that girl was killed in the
hallway of the capital
that i agree with today so our only
option as a practical matter
is to fix what is causing this in the
first place we don't have a choice now
this is where populist
rhetoric this is the i've not
pre-screened this so
tucker might be about to say something i
agree with or something i don't
but one of the things i've talked about
before is how populist
rhetoric sounds very similar on the left
and right
middle class elite suppressing economic
system you know etc
but then the right-wing populist will
say and so we've got to fix this before
black lives matter takes your house
and hispanic immigrants take your jobs
right
so that's the pernicious nature and the
duplicitous nature of populist rhetoric
that it sounds
pretty good and similar left and right
and then you'll see
dramatically ridiculous solutions so
let's see what his solution is
you may have nothing in common with the
people on the other side of the country
increasingly you probably
don't but you're stuck with them the
idea that groups of americans will
somehow break off into separate peaceful
nations of like-minded citizens that's a
fantasy
that will not happen there is no such
thing as a
peaceful separation there never has been
and there won't be
the two hemispheres of this country are
inseparably intertwined
they're co-joined twins neither can
leave without killing the other
so that's the first thing to know as
horrifying as this moment is we have no
option
but to make it better to gut it out the
second thing to consider and it's
related to the first
now what's missing from this is that
trump incited the riot
that that seems com it's very easy you
know
uh it's it's very easy to put this all
together and say
ultimately we have to get along and we
have to seek understanding
but then you're ignoring that trump
incited the riot
and there's one side that is connected
to
an imaginary set of facts that aren't
facts where an election was stolen
and covet is fake and right i mean so
that the they're very quick to be faux
conciliatory
when their side is acutely and solely to
blame for what took place
is why the woman who was killed today
went to the rally in the first place
okay is he going to blame trump now if
he does i will be pleased
we don't know anything about her but she
did not look particularly radical
she brought no resemblance to the angry
children we have seen again and again
wrecking our cities
pasty entitled nihilist dressed in black
so why did she go getting slogans on
statues
she didn't look like that the woman in
the capital hallway looked pretty much
like everyone else
huh so why was she there okay on a
wednesday
right why were any of them there today
we ought to think about that
if you want to fix it you have to think
about that
okay but so is he maybe alluding to
economic circumstances but they were all
right wingers if it's just
unemployed people who are there that
would be a different analysis
the only reason this country is rich and
successful
okay is because for hundreds of years we
have enjoyed a stable political system
and the only reason that system is
stable is because it's a democracy it
responds to voters
okay democracy is our pressure relief
valve
as long as people sincerely believe they
can change things by voting
but why don't they believe that
they don't believe that because trump
told them it was stolen
did wow they stay calm
they don't storm the bastille who made
them not calm
the people claiming it was stolen don't
burst into the house
chamber they talk and they organize and
they vote
but the opposite is also true if people
begin to believe that their democracy is
fraudulent
if they conclude that where did they
come up with that idea
voting is a charade the system is rigged
and it's run in secret by a small group
of powerful dishonest people who are
acting oh my god
and don't tell me that it's a small
group of powerful jewish people because
that would just be too much
in their own interests then god knows
what could happen actually we do know
what could happen
it's happening right now right but is is
he going to does he name trump in this
i don't know that i can go the another
two minutes does he say and this is all
from trump
it's happened in countless other
countries over countless centuries and
the cycle is always the same because
human nature never changes
listen to us screams the population shut
up and do what you're told replied their
leaders
in the face of dissent the first
instinct of illegitimate leadership
is to crack down on the population but
is he calling
another another instinct of illegitimate
leadership is to claim they want to try
to stay in power
but crackdowns never make it better
instead they always make the country
more volatile and more dangerous
it's also funny because there really was
no crackdown yesterday like
the police were missing we're still
trying to figure out where law
enforcement was but
yesterday wasn't the opposite of a
crackdown had it been blm or antifa
doing what we saw yesterday
we would probably have dozens dead
the people in charge really understand
that they don't want to they don't care
to learn or listen because all this
conversation is a referendum on them and
their leadership
so they clamp down harder obey i tell
you obey
this is the romanov program it ends
badly
every single time but that doesn't mean
they won't try it again
of course they will because it's their
nature it's how we got here in the first
place
i mean if he means right-wing people are
going to riot again then yes it does
seem as though they're planning to
millions of americans sincerely believe
the last election
was fake
[Laughter]
but where did they get that idea and is
it based in fact and the answers are
trump and no
all right that's probably all of that
that i can take at this point in time
um i don't know that i can do much more
i see people joining
asking uh did the press conference
already happen yeah it only lasted a
minute and 42 seconds
so i'll i'll play it again just because
people are coming in and out okay
um this it was only a minute and 42
seconds from kaylee mcinanny so i'm i'm
going to play it
and then i have other things i also have
behind the scenes video of don jr
um filming trump watching the start of
the riots
so let's just listen real quick this is
earlier um
and this is uh uh kaylee mcinanna i
won't pause this time okay
i'm really gonna keep it at only a
minute 42 seconds i won't pause at all
i am here to deliver this message on
behalf of the entire white house
let me be clear the violence we saw
yesterday at our nation's capital was
appalling
reprehensible and antithetical to the
american way
we condemn it the president and this
administration
in the strongest possible terms it is
unacceptable
and those that broke the law should be
prosecuted to the fullest extent of the
law
i know it's all lies i stood here at
this podium the day after a historic
church
burned amid violent riots and i said
this
the first amendment guarantees the right
of the people to peaceably assemble
what we saw last night in washington and
across the country was not that
end quote make no mistake what we saw
yesterday afternoon
in the halls of our capital likewise was
not that
we grieve for the loss of life and those
injured
and we hold them in our prayers and
close to our hearts at this time
we thank our valiant law enforcement
officers who are true
american heroes what we saw yesterday
was a group of violent rioters
undermining the legitimate first
amendment rights
of the many thousands who came to
peacefully have their voices heard
in our nation's capital those who
violently besieged our capital
are the opposite of everything this
administration stands for
right the core value of our
administration
is the idea that all citizens have the
right to live in safety
peace and freedom those who are working
in this building
are working to ensure an orderly
transition of power
working very hard now it is time for
america to unite
to come together to reject the violence
that we have seen
we are one american people under god
thank you very much
all right so yeah and by the way i saw
the i see the super chat
about me using the the shortcuts on the
keyboard to stop
the clips instead of flying my mouse
around that's fine i know that it's the
letter k
and i i will do that so yeah it's a
dollar a dollar
a day late and a dollar short as people
are pointing out that was the entire
press briefing no no
people asking where's the rest that
that's the whole thing that was the
entire press briefing there's not this
was all
this was all that she did all right um
okay let's get to the don jr video
before i do that i do want to say thanks
to the 33
additional twitch prime twitch and
twitch prime
subscribers uh which puts us at 115
and then i also want to say a very
powerful thank you um
to the eight additional people that
signed up at joinedpakman.com as you may
know
whoa whoa not not 1123. we're at 123.
as you may know uh in all seriousness
the best way to support the work we do
is to grab a membership at
joinpacman.com we have a coupon code
better21 it's a huge discount it's not
illegal it's not immoral those are just
jokes
just jokes um it's perfectly legal to
take the discount and i
would very much appreciate everybody who
signs up okay this is a video that has
been released
this is don jr this this appears to be
it's not clear to me whether this is
right after trump speaks and tells
everybody let's go to the capitol or
right before
but the crowds are starting to build
here and this is what's going on behind
the scenes this is don jr
and you see trump in the background uh
watching what are what are building
riots this is right before people are
saying
okay thank you all for that uh
it's actually hard to believe
unfortunately there's a road in between
the main crowd and then the masses
love to see them get in closer because
they'd be pretty awesome but uh this is
pretty incredible
[Music]
so anyway yeah i guess i should be
careful because of all the music that's
playing but you'll see
that here's trump and he just seems very
very you know
entertained i guess by he looks at the
crowd
and all of this other garbage i mean
it's just it's it's all
it's just all completely and totally
toxic so there's that
i see requests coming in for the lindsey
graham press conference
i'm glad to look at that is that
something you guys would be interested
in
lindsey graham who's just disgusting
gave a completely sensible speech on the
floor
of the senate early this morning and
it's like it's fine the guy's a loon
and he said something that sort of made
sense because this is the end of
everything
um but he gave a press conference that i
haven't looked at
and all right let's take a look at it
let's just look at a little bit of it
um maybe before we do
hold on let's get to where it actually
starts here's lindsay
before we do that let me just read a few
super chats i do want to get caught up
on a few things people are saying oh
look
david did you see lindsey graham's press
conference today yeah we're about to
look at it
scoop mike pence has rejected the 25th
amendment oh
i want to look at that though that that
seems higher priority
let me see here uh pence
25th let's see what's breaking there
pence is said to oppose invoking the
25th amendment to strip
trump of his duties breaking news from
the new york times
filed two minutes ago okay this is
important mike pence said to oppose
invoking 25th amendment to strip trump
of his duties
vice president mike pence is opposed to
a call by democrats
by in congress and some republicans
to invoke the 25th amendment to remove
president trump before his term ends a
person close to the vice president said
it is unclear when pence will alert
congress of his position
but the decision by mr pence is said to
be supported by several trump cabinet
officials those officials a senior
republican said viewed the effort as
likely to add to the current chaos in
washington rather than deter it
see i disagree with this reasoning this
is sort of like
should we impeach because it might anger
people
you have a duty to do what is right
and then to deal with the consequences
of it you don't say
we won't impeach there is only one
consideration when you determine whether
or not to impeach did the president do
something impeachable
that's it did the president do something
impeachable
uh and likewise here is the president
fit to serve
this this explanation the effort is
likely to add to the chaos
that's garbage okay is the president fit
to serve consider
that donald trump can't be trusted to
post on twitter
he can't be trusted to post on facebook
he can't be trusted to post on instagram
and he's lost all of those privileges
but he has access to nukes he has access
to nukes even though he's too volatile
and untrustworthy to post to facebook so
this
this is not a good explanation for me
but it is not surprising
it is not surprising that's the breaking
news mike pence says he opposes invoking
the 25th
uh okay let's get to the senator lindsey
graham press conference
in a second here um braden says
hold them accountable cool kaylee now do
sedition
oh and incitement of lawlessness is
unprotected speech
that's all true vina gadapali
with a strong 50 super chat says you're
awesome thank you so much for keeping me
sane
during these crazy times chong lin
says would you support a yang ticket in
2024
listen andrew yang is running for new
york city mayor and
as is always my policy i we need to
before i'm willing to talk about 2024
joe biden needs to become president
we need to see what happens with andrew
yang in the new york city mayoral race
we need the 2022 midterms we need to see
what's happening with the democratic
primary
it's there's no reason for me to get
involved in that at this point in time
okay let's get to the lindsay press
briefing i am curious
to see what he was asked and what he
said let's take a look here
do we want it in real time or do we want
it at like 1.25 x or one and a half what
do you guys want
just regular speed
i guess we'll do let's let's do regular
speed
yeah check and see yeah i don't want to
i don't want to
speak if he's speaking
everybody okay
we are going to need him on mike i'm
sure he gets on mike right
kind of weird all right we'll do 1.25
playback speed 1.25 but just a slightly
sped up lindsey graham beautiful
okay okay
there he goes all good all good so as
you can imagine everybody
in politics and at the federal level was
asked a lot of questions by people in
the media
what was yesterday like what does it all
mean rather than
doing a bunch of interviews i thought
i'd give a my view of what happened
yesterday and the way forward for the
country
and try to get back to south carolina
and
and help the transition here uh the
first thing that stands out to me
is how embarrassed and disgusted i am
that the united states capital will be
taken over by domestic terrorists
while we're in session okay i i like i
like
calling them domestic terrorists i like
that from one president to the other
that a band of people who are terrorists
not patriots
literally occupied the floor of the
house drove the senate out of its
chamber
and the question for the country is how
could that happen 20 years after 9 11.
september this year will be the 20th
anniversary of the attack on our nation
right it is mind-boggling that such an
event could occur
uh senator schumer's call for the
secretary sergeant arms the senate to
resign
i echo that anyone in charge
of defending the capital
is that you two
anyone in charge of defending the
capital failed uh
in their duties if they would have been
in the military they had been relieved
of their commands and
most likely court-martialed so the first
thing that has to happen
is to hold those accountable for failing
to defend the nation's capital
while the congress was in session fair
but we've there's probably a thousand
people or more that also need to be
arrested
why am i worried it would have been so
easy for a terrorist organization
to infiltrate this movement the lone
wolf
terrorist i think we've got a pretty
good grip on but political
protest in this yes we know that the if
the person has brown skin it's
definitely not a lone wolf the
republican party has put together a very
cohesive standpoint on that country is
the heart and soul of who we are
but we haven't been protesting lately
we've been burning down cities
we've been attacking federal courthouses
we've been looting in the name of social
justice
so now he's mostly focused on things
other than what happened yesterday
and now we've occupied the capital this
needs to stop to my democratic
colleagues i share your
this again remember all that other stuff
he mentioned
accurate or not was not incited by his
golf buddy the president
and so when these guys lump it all
together and say we're against all of it
the president was only inciting the
stuff from yesterday and that's his
friend
disgust and embarrassment and
determination
to make sure that what happened in our
capital never happens again but you need
to speak up
when this happens in other places
lawliness
right but so but so now that's a false
that's false logic
he seems to be suggesting if people had
spoken up about the george floyd
protests
which by the way were almost perfect um
not completely than yesterday wouldn't
have happened but trump incited
yesterday is he saying
trump wouldn't have incited yesterday if
someone had stopped the george floyd
protest it's incoherent
lawlessness in one place breeds
lawlessness everywhere
i think that's the exact phrase uh
tucker used when one cause
resorts devour violence and people are
not prosecuted other causes
believe maybe this is okay so the
mistake we made is when people
try to destroy the courthouse in
portland even the protesters themselves
consider themselves of a different
species than the george floyd protesters
right
like the idea so so the other thing
that's crazy about this is
yesterday's criminals essentially see
the floyd blm antifa protesters as
sub-human
so the idea that the people from
yesterday
would say well you know what we're going
to guide our behavior
by what those other protesters did over
the summer
they don't consider themselves
equivalent to those people why why would
they be looking to them for guidance on
behavior
lin they weren't prosecuted the full
extent of law give me a break dude
when they occupied seattle they weren't
prosecuted to the fullest
oh this is a joke the attack the the
acceptance of the nomination
by president trump here in d.c virtually
no one was prosecuted
it's good to hear everybody wanting
prosecutions
okay some are late to the dance i was
there from day one
so let's reset and move forward and tell
every
political movement out there no matter
how just your calls in your own mind
using violence will not advance your
cause it will it will only lead to your
personal incarceration
or if you go too far to injury so listen
on this issue i believe i have actually
been consistent for a decade which has
been
i am not only opposed to the violence
morally i also believe it's
counterproductive
this was a debate
between dr martin luther king jr and
malcolm x
they had different views on this and i
have an entire interview on my youtube
channel with a professor about that a
scholar of both dr martin luther king
and and malcolm x i've been consistent
on this from from day one
and with the george floyd protests i was
against the violence and
you guys know that what these guys do
is when it's the george floyd antifa
whatever even if it's 99 percent
peaceful they say violent leftists
antifa etc when it's undeniable that
it's their side they retreat to
we need to come together and we're
against all violence
so what am i calling for i'm calling for
a joint task force to be
assembled oh now we need a task force
and spend all the time and money
necessary
to identify every person who breached
the security of the capital i agree
will occupy the chambers yes who invaded
offices
and destroyed property there's a ton of
video evidence out there
i was interviewed this morning by two
fbi agents they came to my house wanting
to know if i had any surveillance
cameras outside my house i did not but
i'm encouraged they're on the case
trust me in the social media world it
exists today it will be not
won't be that hard to find thousands of
people
who took the law in their own hands the
people sitting in the chairs
need to be sitting in a jail cell the
people who attacked the capitol police
you know he has some responsibility for
this in the sense that he's one of the
people
who has often egged on trump not
specifically i'm saying about yesterday
but trump he has emboldened trump into
thinking
into getting trump to think that he is a
good decision maker that he should trust
his instincts which are terrible
and and uh on and on and on and he's
very very late to the game here
need to be charged with attacking a
police officer
sedition may be a charge for some of
these people trump
so i will for the next six years god
willing
every week ask of the department of
justice starting with this department of
justice
and the next department justice what
kind of progress are you making
in holding those accountable the
domestic terrorists who took over the
house and the senate chambers
i hope he does in late ways i don't
believe it but i hope he does
what do you need that you don't have if
you need more prosecutors
money will not be an object if you need
more investigators
we'll provide you the resources this is
a moment for the nation to show will and
determination
so so far i mean listen the the real
headline yesterday
is that trump incited the mob
and that it was all motivated by false
claims
of election theft that's the top line
that this would be like
you know you look at an article uh
and you know that you've got your
headline and you've got your sub
headline
and then you've got kind of like the
main point this would be like lindsay
saying hey
i'm going to issue a really important
statement about what happened
and talking about like this you know
imagine if i was like hey guys let's
talk about trump pardoning himself
and then all i tell you is mueller
outlined 10 instances where trump might
have obstructed justice
that's the story hold on what about this
what about this what about this that's
what lindsey graham is doing here
where the main thing is this all started
because trump has been claiming for two
months that he really won which he
didn't
and then yesterday he incited a mob that
did exactly what he said which is go to
the capitol down pennsylvania ave
that's missing so far be a nation of
laws that anarchy shall not reign
the constitution controls not the mob
yesterday i was proud of senator
mcconnell the republican leader of the
senate
who stood up and called for a peaceful
transfer of power to vice president
biden and kamala harris
like senator mcconnell i supported
president trump i've become
close to the president personally we
know i think his president has been
consequential from a conservative point
of view
it has been an amazing four years in
terms of judges securing the border
oh my god vaccine in record time vaccine
has nothing to do with the economy
cutting taxes
historic mideast peace agreements so now
he goes off the rails we could do either
one of those really like historic mid
peace agreements
agreements between countries that had
already re-established diplomatic
relationships
peace agreement what are you talking
about dude the destruction of the
caliphate
on and on and on was tarnished by
yesterday
when it comes to accountability the
president needs to understand
that his actions were the problem not
the solution
ah okay that's good that i like that the
rally yesterday
was unseemly it got out of hand and a
good friend of mine rudy giuliani did
not help
perfect i said on the floor of the
senate
i cast my vote accordingly that joe
biden
is the legitimate president-elect of the
united states we know are there
irregularities in this election yes i'm
sure they are
have they been overblown absolutely
there's been a constant effort
by people from the president's legal
team to provide misinformation
to distort the facts to make accusations
that cannot be proven
that needs to stop as to the 25th
amendment being invoked
i do not believe that's appropriate at
this point i'm looking for a peaceful
transfer of power
i'm looking for the next 14 days to
reset
and we will hand off power in a
traditional sense by
being a peaceful transfer i talked to
mark meadows this morning
the transition is going well and what
does that mean
is it could there be a more meaningless
statement because it's so vague
the transition is going well really did
you see the video
fully in place i talked to the
president's legal counsel pat sipoloni
he is doing everything he can to help
the transfer occur as do to these
two gentlemen most americans will never
know
the service that mark meadows and pat
sipoloni and their
those under their charge they have been
some of the worst enablers of donald
trump of this entire presidency
the idea of praising mark meadows and
pat cipolloni
is inconceivable to me invited to this
country
over the last year talked to secretary
mnuchin today who's in israel
no one will fully understand what he and
others have brought to the table
so to those who believe you should leave
your posts now to make a statement i
would urge you not
to robert o'brien you've been getting a
good counsel to the president so i'm
getting ready to kind of wind down i
don't know
if people want the full 45 minutes of
this but i'm getting the gist of what
he's saying which is some light
criticism of trump but mostly saying
trump's grade and
kind of talking about other pro i'm kind
of getting a gist i don't know how long
we need to stay with it
you've been a steady hand i've been
missing your phone calls robert stay on
to those in the national security
apparatus we need you now more than ever
so i embrace oh okay people are saying
when he takes questions it changes let
me get to that
do we know exactly when that is uh oh it
looks like it's here let's take a listen
move forward
to my democratic colleagues i ask the
same of you
then i'll take questions senator graham
you were one of president trump's
biggest critics
during the 2016 election he became one
of his biggest supporters do you have
any regrets
in your support of him and what this has
led to at this moment uh
no uh i was a opponent of president
trump and i got beat like a drum
i didn't scratch i had a decision to
make surprising he's not saying i got
beat like a dog as donald trump says
said everything i could think about
regarding him as a candidate
the people of south carolina spoke you
when my stadium became president united
states
so i decided then it's not about me it's
about
my job as being a senator from south
carolina people from south carolina
wanted me to work with this president
and i did
i did the same with obama i'll do the
same with biden i like that
obama obama but this is a republican
president
he changed my opinion of who he was
through his actions mine too
right just let me get there the reason
i've
been close to the president is i think
he's done tremendous
things for this country i think the
judges he has nominated
have been outstanding choices and we saw
yesterday an independent judiciary
i think people like bill barr were the
best people in the country to be
attorney general at the time they were
so i think that this happened hours
before bill barr said trump betrayed the
country
i think what he did to destroy the
caliphate was long overdue it makes us
safer
i think getting out of the iran uh
nuclear agreement has led the way
to peace between the arabs and the
israelis at a level i would never have
imagined
i think he's brought what order to the
border what he listened to me
he asked my advice about judges when i
got upset about syria he listened
and he actually changed his policies i
could never get obama
to do that obama obama had a good
relationship with him
but was senator mccain we begged him do
not leave her well the reason you could
so
trump's an idiot that's why you're able
to convince that's so funny he's like
you know for some reason i was able to
convince trump to do stuff and not
barack obama i don't know it's just
that's that's i would consider that
praise of obama rock
but he did as to yesterday it breaks my
heart
that my friend a president of a
consequence would allow yesterday to
happen
and it will allow be a major part
of his presidency it was a
self-inflicted wound
true it was going too far and here's one
thing i can say
the next two weeks can begin to right
the ship depending on how the president
behaves
and over time his presidency will be
viewed in a fuller context
i have absolutely no regrets of helping
this president
make a safer more prosperous so you're
disgusting i relationship with him
i say these things not because of
animosity i say these things because i
have to
we'll do one more after being so close
to this president for four years
do you think that you and other
republicans had more of a responsibility
to speak out
both privately and publicly when he said
things that were untrue when he ginned
up
his base do you think that that would
have made a difference yesterday i think
the trump presidency has been poorly
covered by people in your business
i think that from the time he took
office do you have any responsibility
because you didn't uh dissuade trump
from this stuff
i think you're the problem media there's
been an
effort to cover his presidency in a way
that i think is
not helpful to the country i have spoken
up
the coverage of trump isn't helpful but
what about trump has trump been helpful
it's been an effort to believe
everything that trump did was wrong
before it's proven
or not all i can say is that i have
shared my
thoughts with the president i've spoken
out when i thought i should
but the one thing that i want you to
know there are plenty of republicans
believe
that the trump presidency was never
legitimate in the eyes of the democratic
party
never accepted by the people in your
business that's that's really not true
it's crazy not to mention so he's doing
an entire press conference about
violence that was caused fundamentally
because of the false notion that the
election was
was stolen from from donald trump and he
falsely says
the media and democrats never accepted
that trump was president
what what all right
so we're going to get away from that i'm
going to open the phone lines in a
moment but i did want to mention this um
simon and schuster where did that go
hold on a second
simon schuster has cancelled plans for
josh hawley's book
the publisher faced calls to drop the
missouri republicans upcoming book the
tyranny of big tech following criticism
of his efforts to overturn the
presidential election
this is what you call the free market my
friends this is what you call the free
market
um josh hawley arguably the most
prominent senator the first senator who
said that he would be objecting
uh to the election results being counted
and he was going to be writing a book
for simon
schuster simon schuster has canceled it
this is not censorship
this is nothing other than the free
market simon schuster's a for-profit
company they've determined
they don't want the profit that they
would or would not be able to get so
that that's all that that is
um and then lastly um i'm told that
there is an aoc
tweet that just went out
um
i don't know what this is
is there an election yeah i don't i
don't know that this is that relevant to
this stream
okay so that's that is uh that is that
all right let me say a huge thank you
to the 18 additional twitch
subscribers 18 which puts us at 141
and also a big thank you to the
13 people who just signed up at
joinpakman.com
which puts us at 154 so let's open some
phone lines and remember that we will be
streaming
all sorts of things leading up to and
including
the inauguration of joseph r biden jr
um if you're watching on youtube make
sure to hit that subscribe button
the our our subscribe button has
actually been broken for 24 hours
so many people subscribed yesterday
during the insanity of this riotous
insurrectionist coup that uh the the
subscribe button essentially broke
where youtube said we've got to verify
these subscriptions one at a time
because we want to make sure
bots are not being used and if you're
watching
on twitch also make sure to give us a
follow so you're notified in the future
let's hear from some folks you can get a
hold of me
via discord davidpakman.com discord and
get into the waiting lobby
very very easy davidpakman.com
discord get into the waiting lobby
um let's see what it's on
what is on people's minds we'll just
check in with a few people here let's go
to paul
from the bronx paul from the bronx
you're on the air
paul from the bronx please unmute
yourself and you will be able to talk to
me
oh i did not expect to get caught up
that fast i didn't either to be honest
it surprised me
give me one second there we go okay
so there yes i'm here okay yeah um
i just i i just literally just joined
the call i didn't expect to get pulled
in
my apologies about that um i just want
to talk about
the and excuse my language the absolute
[ __ ] show
that happened yesterday um i'm not sure
what else could be
said about it it was supposed to be a
humdrum uh
process you know ceremonial exactly yeah
it's supposed to just be like
uh pence is over there just handing the
tellers everything and
you know uh the objections is what
really bothered me
mostly because of what everybody was
trying to cite
uh they were effectively trying to cite
that uh the federal government should
have been able to interfere
with the state-based constitutions and
i'm just there like
but that's not what you're here for
right you're only here for
just to confirm what the state sent in
like anything besides that
you guys are just monkeying up and to
make matters worse it wasn't like
i was actually kind of shocked that that
the senate didn't pass any
um it was just the house represented
house representatives in the republican
side like they just wanted to go ahead
and just
you know stomp their feet and make a
bunch of noise that's the
only thing that's the only reason why it
dragged on from
what was it nine o'clock to four am in
the morning when they finally finished
of course it never had a chance of
achieving anything they were they were
citing objections that are not even
within their purview to to analyze
you're absolutely right and that i think
was lost on a lot of people that
even this idea of whether they should or
shouldn't object they were objecting on
grounds that have nothing to do with
their role
exactly like um somebody one of them was
signing like the error rate of the state
and i'm just there like
that's not you right the state's
certified already
period right right and and even now
there's still some people that still
trying to go back and say oh well we
have a way to detect the ballots and i'm
like
okay if you guys determine it you guys
know you missed the federal deadline
right
so there's nothing else that can be done
a state a set of electives have already
been duly chosen
right it's over and yes the the the
insurrection that happened yesterday too
also exacerbated things like
in a way it helped like it kind of put
some senators in place like i can't back
your play anymore
like um kelly kelly loffler she backed
off
um yep going on ahead and objecting uh
yeah i actually think you know i
actually
i think it's even though it took till 3
4 a.m
if they had objected in six states and
had two hours of debate in each of them
it would have taken that long anyway
like in a sense the insurrection
delayed but it also eliminated a bunch
of the objections
and and in the end the the certification
happened
roughly when it was going to anyway
exactly even if you're included all the
time yeah
it was just it was this this whole
entire thing was just an exercise and
i just want to be the contrarian and i
want to show everybody i'm on donald
trump's side all of this
is just to feed into 2022
when the next set of elect elections are
beh are being held for the house
yeah it was it was essentially
right-wing virtue signaling
exactly that that's all that was it was
an exercise a virtual signal
all right my friend i appreciate it by
the way it sounds like there's a bell
ringing in the background do you hear
that um
it might be it just might be because
this new pc that i have going off or my
cell phone's ringing off i
literally just have my mic set up i
didn't even like check everything to see
if it worked oh i gotcha no well i
appreciate you calling in
no problem thank you all right take care
uh very very strong call there from the
bronx
new york let's go next to
you know there are so many people that
have been trying to call in from germany
i'm not going to be able to get to all
of them it's just
there's actually a bunch of people
holding but let's just
try dominic from germany if we can
oh yeah so i actually did not expect to
speak here but
first of all big fan thank you for
listening so yeah yes i just just uh saw
live stream from
the whole thing which happened there in
the capital and i was actually quite
shocked
especially here in germany we have a one
fair share of
facial fascia's uh history and it was
really scary to see that
yes um so my question is basically
bain biden needs to do so many things at
once he needs to
satisfy all the progressives us with uh
very important collector term sorry
topics like climate change
and all of that at the same time he
needs to basically
go against all the trump supporters and
basically convince them of what what uh
what
what's the real how you can actually
govern this country um and at the same
time he needs to
satisfy all the moderate republican
republicans and democrats and how do you
think he is able to do that or is there
any way
how he can maybe achieve that there is
no way and i don't even think he should
try there's no way and he shouldn't even
try
i think it's fine for joe biden to say i
look forward to working with republicans
i will be the president for everybody i
think that that's all great
but um it would be completely naive to
think
that these hyper-obstructionist
republicans are all of a sudden going to
help him do anything now if
if republicans believe it will be good
for them
uh they might go with an infrastructure
plan that includes some sustainable
shifts in energy for example if it'll
create jobs in their states
if they think it's good for them if they
think that two thousand dollar stimulus
checks
uh will be good for them they may go
along with it right but
uh no he's not going to be able to
satisfy anybody he shouldn't even try
yeah okay so thank you very much for
your for my christmas my pleasure uh
dominic from germany great to hear from
you
let's see uh why don't we go next to
uh let's go to vitali from israel um
what is it what is it 2 30 in the
morning there vitale
hello hello can you hear me yes i can
thanks it's a quarter two two no
wow that's that's a strong time yeah
well uh the pandemic kind of uh
messed up my sleep schedule is that
right how so
well uh i got unemployed uh recently and
just
uh because i don't have a scheduled
normal schedule to the day i
i see i see have you been have you been
vaccinated
um not as of yet i only got my mother
convinced my mother to do it next week
okay
i managed to do it because she got
scared because of the internet obviously
yeah and just one last question what
part of israel are you in
uh the north the north
did you say haifa yes oh very
interesting yeah i've been to
haifa uh i went to the baha'i gardens of
course
very touristy i'm sure um my
cousin graduated from haifa university
um beautiful part of the country
yes it's a one of the more special
cities well i've said enough what can i
do for you today
yeah i was uh just wanted to express
my feelings about yesterday and today
about
the state of united states and
our relationship with the united states
most israel is
seeing trump as a good president for
israel
uh but they seen it because of the very
short term uh effects right
especially when relay in relation to the
palestinian israel palestinian uh
conflict
now as far as that goes did anybody
believe jared kushner was really going
to solve the israeli-palestinian
conflict
no good they did not but uh
they thought that we would might bring a
better deal and the
trump deal was seen pretty favorably by
most people here
right uh although it's obvious nobody
will
ever agree to it on the other side and
it will never be
enforced of course
and the thing is that the way i see it
uh israel doesn't need an ally in the
united states that it just
does whatever israel wants it needs a
healthy ally
right a health democracy that is
sustainable and is
not fickle because well it will take
like
very little for trump to just shift
like it would be enough for bibi
netanyahu
i mean uh to say something that would
upset
trump and the whole thing would come
apart
sure and in any case trump has 13 days
left so we're moving beyond that
yes but yesterday uh got me
sick and actually scared to my stomach
because of
what the implications to american
democracy it might mean
yeah no you and me both yes and uh
i just wanted to express that thank you
all right thank you appreciate the call
okay uh very good uh vitalia's vitali is
gone
um let's see who else we want to talk to
via discord at davidpakman.com
discord we've gone uh we've really gone
around the world
uh oh you know who i want to check in
with i want to check in with liberal
cluck
hey did you did you end up at the
insurrection yesterday
i did but i unfortunately couldn't
stream it my uh data started crapping
out on me
well listen what what did you did you
see anything notable what was the
wackiest thing you saw
um well wacky oh my gosh
uh like people dressed up in military
garb and stuff sometimes i had trouble
um but not them they weren't the i'm
guessing they weren't the military
though
yeah yeah they were i like i would have
trouble like deciphering between like
who was cops and who was uh
trump supporter sometimes i actually
followed one guy thinking he was a cop
and i was going to ask him a question
and yeah
it turned out to be a trump supporter
now did you see people
did you see the the the the rioters um
uh did you see them carrying firearms
i actually didn't see any open carrying
or firearms i
know for a fact they were there um but
uh
like i said i'm sure they were there i
just i wasn't looking for that i was
like keeping my phone trying to keep my
phone above the crowd
i mean i think it would be i don't think
people would i don't think people would
really be open caring because
i don't think these out-of-staters would
legally be allowed to do that in dc but
i guess i'm wondering if
you saw somebody with a firearm that you
know maybe they were not
trying to make it clear that they were
carrying i don't know
oh no no i didn't but like i said i
wasn't looking for that and
yeah i'm sure they were there fair fair
um
so there is a couple things i would like
to point out about um
what i did see um first of all
if anyone has any of these lunatics and
their um
family that thinks this was antifa yeah
i want you to ask
them so i i i got on tape uh the second
time
that um that they were trying to push
through the guards
to get into the capitol yeah um and uh
and i want you to ask them if that was
antifa trying to do that then why was
the
thousands of trump supporters in the
crowd
cheering them on saying things like
heave hov
heave hope right in other words so
you're saying that
even if it were true that everybody who
physically did something was antifa that
the entire crowd of trumpus was cheering
it on
they sure were yes they were um there
were some exceptions the guy next to me
actually said something to the effect of
i want to support this but that would be
like supporting a tifa or something like
that
right but you know i appreciate the
consensus consistency at least
sure um something some other things that
i saw
during that second push that was the one
that i was i was up top
for so i was able to like really really
see um
the people like scaling the walls yeah
um
to to get down to the crowd which was
like does this guy even care if he lives
or dies
um guys trying to like hit the police
with sticks
really just like sticks they picked up
off the ground
well i i guess they brought like large
batons and he was like on top of the
crowd
trying to like javel his way into um
the at the cops they already he was like
literally trying uh trying to hit him
with sticks there was another guy who
was like
kicking the cops from like from like the
top of the doorway
um and uh pepper spray
somebody brought pepper spray sprayed it
over top of the crowd into the cops
um and by the way the people that were
like scaling the wall
were there not stairs available was that
necessary
um i i couldn't find a
a legit way to get up there um i wanted
to get up there just to see what it was
what was going on i ended up into there
was like scaffolding on the sides which
i guess was put there for the like
speakers for people to stand on when
they were speakers yeah yeah
and um they they were just so
packed full like the legitimate ways
they were just so packed full of people
trying to get through
up and down um that i actually ended up
just climbing the poles of the
scaffolding to get up to the top so i
can get a good vantage point
really now do you think you committed
any crimes yesterday
i did not um everywhere that i went was
um
was like legit like where people should
have been
at least i believe they were not
committed any crimes it certainly wasn't
um
wasn't intentional okay well then we
know any any unintentional crimes those
aren't really crimes
uh yeah that's that's true um i
i just got there by like um like weird
uh methods yeah climbing the scaffolding
i don't know if that's allowed
um i assumed it was for people to stand
on so that uh they can like watch the
speaker or something that's that's what
it looked like oh you mean like the
stanchions
i thought you were okay i misunderstood
when you said climb the scaffolding i
thought you meant like
the scaffolding that's behind the stage
that's used to like put lighting up on
and like
that clearly i think you weren't
supposed to be on oh well maybe i did do
so maybe that's what that was for
you may have committed crimes yeah you
may have committed no
oh gosh um it wasn't intentional i
promise well listen at least you're on
here as liberal cluck
so nobody knows your name that is true
um
yeah you mean bleachers bleachers right
that's what you meant
that's what i meant yes i was on the
bleacher perfect perfect perfect
i'm not about to upload a video that uh
that contradicts that at all
sure so don't don't go onto my channel
to look for that all right good and then
just one last thing
was it notable that there were just like
not nearly enough law enforcement people
around
definitely oh my gosh i i when i got
there i was just like
well first of all when i got there i
heard one of the trumpets say that the
police are leaving
this was after the first like break-in
yeah um and then i got there and i was
just like
this is crazy there was like there was
like a bunch of them standing on top
and they look bored as like there was a
as their people down at the doorway was
like trying to keep
a large crowd of people from getting in
um
and hey listen this is not let i don't
want you to be indiscreet with this but
you know when when people are when
there's this number of people around for
eight hours i i mean what
where were people going to the bathroom
were they walking away and going to
starbucks in the middle of the
insurrection or was it was it becoming a
vile
disgusting situation i did not smell any
bodily fluids
i know myself i just held it the entire
time okay
um but uh yeah i didn't smell it they
had to have had bathrooms set up i
didn't even think about that to be
honest
yeah i don't know how to have bathroom
set up let's hope nobody left any gifts
in nancy's desk if you know what i'm
saying oh my gosh
yeah oh all right well listen i really
appreciate the report
all right not a problem mom i appreciate
you having me on all right i also
appreciate you letting me
letting me plug the other day i got a
butt load of people that followed me on
twitter and everything from that so
thank you
all right yes it's liberal cluck liberal
cluck thank you very much appreciate the
call
wow really a lot a lot a lot um
going on there oh you know who's let's
go to our friend matilda from sweden uh
we've spoken before right matilda
yes we have how are you
i'm good thank you now let me see if i
can remember
did you say you're in uppsala
yes you are oh i do i remember beautiful
i remember exactly then
yeah well what's going on today you
remember
i do i thought we could talk a bit about
the police and why there
they didn't
apprehend the or they weren't
a lot of police there right yeah and uh
so the crowd took over and
uh did all the things uh that they did
right and i was thinking
because we have the same problem here in
sweden
actually with the right wing not
being taken seriously by the police
right
and i agree with you you said you didn't
think
that it was a conspiracy
or that it was orchestrated by the
police no no
i'm i'm not saying that i'm saying there
are some alleging that but i am not
saying that
yeah yeah i agree with you that that
sounds
or that that's not um
something that sounds uh like it's true
okay but uh
i think that that problem is
something that's um a problem in
many different countries right the
police
don't take right-wing extremists
seriously sure if you know what i mean
and uh we have had the same problem here
with protests that has escalated
and it is a problem
understood yeah
all right so what do you think about
that yes uh i mean it is a problem
it is a problem and uh you know we
sometimes we
we joke but we are often not joking
that if the protesters had mostly been a
different skin color
that everything would have been
different if it was an anticipated
antifa black lives matter protest
the preparations would have been
different and you know a lot of
businesses did board up
the businesses seemed to know what was
coming but we still just don't know
enough about why the police response was
what it was we just don't know yet
no we need more information absolutely
but do you think that the fbi knew that
something was
going to happen absolutely i mean i
think you could argue maybe they didn't
know the exact scope but they had to
know to some degree
yeah because there were some groups that
were like
organized and and in all seriousness
the fb if you can help the fbi identify
some of the individuals
in the videos and pictures please
contact
your local fbi office or the one in
washington dc
because we there need to be
repercussions these people need to be
arrested and charged
yes all right matilda well you've said
it all any anything important
happening in sweden i should know about
uh covet rages on here yeah
there's chaos in
uh at the hospitals and uh
the the healthcare workers are
uh yeah they're they're crashing right
now
how are elements of vaccination moving
forward are they available
uh they are starting with
the elderly okay so they are going
around to
different kinds of uh elderly homes
and vaccinated those people first
understood understood yeah all right
matilda thank you
you're not depressed are you you sound a
little down today
i'm not depressed it's uh nearly 1am
oh okay oh my goodness well i don't want
to keep you then so
it's i'm a little bit tired fair
fair sleep so that's why i wanted to
call well listen it's great speaking
to you again yeah all right matilda from
sweden thank you so much hope to hear
from you again
let's go to linus from texas linus from
texas here on the air
linus from texas please unmute and i
would love to talk to you
and linus from texas last opportunity
and linus is gone missing the
opportunity
uh okay why don't we go to
there are a lot i'm just being very
transparent there's a lot of people
waiting to get on right now uh let's go
to
larry from glasgow hello
how are you hi david um i'm fine how are
you doing
you know i've noticed that with the with
the
with the chat audience uh
they seem to love phone calls from
scotland for whatever reason oh
that's pretty good um i didn't actually
expect to get on today but um
you know it's pretty good um yeah um so
i suppose my question is um what do you
think
the impact of like the capitol hill
riots and
even just like the end of trump's
presidency yeah what do you think that
could
what effect that could actually have on
places in europe um or even like the uk
or even specifically scotland if
you have any thoughts on that yeah i
mean i think it's going to be generally
just a slow renormalization of
of these relationships that have been
become a laughing stock under trump
um you know it's it's not even about
foreign policy at this point it's not
about what is going to be joe biden's
policy towards scotland or or whatever
yeah
it's really just about can we get back
to something that's more normal can the
us be marginally more respected globally
and i think it i actually think it'll
happen relatively quickly i don't think
it'll take that long because
i think there's an eagerness for many of
our historical allies to restore a sense
of normalcy so i think it'll actually
happen relatively quickly
yeah hopefully um i was rather concerned
with the whole brexit stuff and how that
would affect trade
and between um the us and the uk
um but you know overall i'm pretty happy
that biden is going to be president and
i wish your country like the best of
luck and
yeah you know from from like europe this
is kind of an embarrassment to see the
united states yeah in this kind of state
but you know what
[ __ ] yeah frick you know what i mean
we'll get through that right i hope that
i hope that you're right
listen are you i'm curious are you
originally from southern
scotland well um i don't i don't
actually think so i'm from like kind of
central to um western scotland
interesting
the only reason i ask is we had a
scottish caller yesterday
who had a different scottish accent than
you and indicated there are different
scottish accents so i was just totally
yeah yeah so like
glasgow um especially doesn't say ken
so when i say i know something i'll say
i know it but if someone from edinburgh
or aberdeen says
they'll know something they'll say oh
you know ken what i mean like hey
or i'll say oh yeah i know this or i
know that you know
dialects and let me ask you this the the
um
the room that's down below the first
floor do you call that the basement or
the cellar
um well i'm particularly americanized
because i've spent a long time
consuming american culture okay i call
it the basement
and i'm pretty sure people in my family
would call it a basement but you know
i'm pretty sure it's kind of variated
between people you know cell our
basement you know
we call like loft at the attic or they
act the loft you know i mean so
we kind of have different words for us
wait you call the basement aloft
oh sorry i should clarify we call the
basement like um
we'll call that basement but we'll call
the attic aloft oh the attic a lot oh
that makes
okay that makes sense yeah yeah yeah and
and as far as um
the uh if the the carbonated beverages
do you call them
soda pop coke what do you call it so
what i call them personally from where i
grew up is called ginger
right and that's basically that kind of
i think that comes from wait a second
hold on a second
you call every soda a coke ginger
um so we don't call every soda like a
coke ginger what we'll call it is we'll
call ever like soda or what you guys
would
call soda pop you call that ginger um or
fizzy dress or something like that
that usually comes from iron brew which
is a orange juice and we refer to
orange as ginger in scotland hold on a
second wait wait wait wait
whoa hold on we're gonna have to back up
we're gonna have to back up you're
saying
some people call every soda coke ginger
but you mean orange juice by by coke
what so i should clarify so yeah no one
in scotland calls it coke ginger
all right that's what can you what is
coke ginger is that a ginger flavored
coke
coke ginger doesn't exist but that's
probably that that would be that'd be
pretty cool um but
ginger overall is like how we encompass
fizzy juice or
pop or soda coke we'll just call that
like coke coca-cola
pepsi you know everyday iron bro is i
think where
the term ginger when referring to fizzy
juice comes from i think that's
specifically where it comes from i could
be wrong
are you saying fizzy or fuzzy fuzzy so
you know how like um carbonated juice
with the bubbles
yeah and all about carbonation yeah yeah
okay yeah so we refer to that as like
fizz okay because it makes a fizzy sound
so okay
okay yeah yeah exactly so we have face i
associate that fizzy juice
ginger stuff like that but here let me
see if i can i really want to get an
answer here to the question i'm trying
to ask which is
if we talk are you familiar with the
beverage sprite
yes okay the category is sprite
a soda is it a pop is it a
coke what is the category under which
you would put sprite
um i would call it i would call it like
fizzy i suppose or like a ginger i would
just call it ginger right
um i don't i don't know what anyone else
would call it
i think we just use it interchangeably
um like i don't i don't know if we
differentiate between
like pop or soda or fizzy just aren't
like we just kind of like throw it into
the one kind of
category and then just call it ginger i
suppose and are you so i want to make
sure you're ta
when you say are you saying the word
that's spelled g-i-n-g-e-r that's the
word yes so gender hair
um you know that's that's how we refer
to i suppose
so my mind is blown i'm not gonna lie my
mind is blown by this
yeah yeah it's pretty good yeah that's
that's unbelievable that's okay
all right good well listen i uh let's
clip that and i really appreciate the
call
no problem thank you very much for
having me pleasure um
plea please clip it meme it remix it
clip meme remix we need that we need
that on the subreddit we need that on uh
you know we need that on dgg
we need that's a that i don't i need to
go and learn i clearly am lacking
very important information very
important information
oh this is our first caller ever from a
beautiful city the city of montevideo
in uruguay a user who apparently goes by
the name
grisha which means grasshopper you're on
the air
we're on a delay oh boy
so we have someone here from the country
of uruguay
in uruguay they speak very similar
spanish to in buenos aires it's called
rio platense spanish so our friend
grisho
is going to be asking his question in
spanish i will then translate an answer
in english
okay so the question is a great one
which is is the the departure of trump
going to have the effect of uh
a downfall of these type of trumpian
right populist authoritarian types or
is the downfall and departure of trump
going to actually serve
as a seed to make a little literal
translation from what our friend said
uh and it and we will actually see it
grow i believe
that in the immediate we are going to
see a boost
i think that trump leaving so listen you
and i and many in the audience we see
what happened yesterday
and we see that as a humiliating failure
we see it as embarrassing it was a
disaster but
we know from the work that the
anti-defamation league and others are
doing
that many of the insurrectionists see
yesterday as a success
and so when they see that those actions
they count those riots as a success
but they see trump leaving and they're
angry and they believe it was rigged
i think in the immediate you will see a
boost in trumpism
type stuff around the world and then in
the medium and long term i don't know i
hope there's a decline
but i think it's too soon to tell
the video question
wow wow what a call so what that
gentleman said
who is originally from argentina but now
lives in uruguay is that there were
trump supporters marching in tokyo let's
just take a look at that
[Music]
[Applause]
wow that's depressing huh
it almost seems like a kind of
performance art but that is
what it what a time to be alive it's
that is insane
absolutely insane uh okay
let me go next to
uh oh let's go to dave from tampa tampa
florida
dave from tampa you're on
dave from tampa you're on the air oh my
god
dave from tampa you're on the air oh my
god i'm sorry
dave go ahead you're on uh can you hear
me
yes we can oh my god okay fantastic uh
i'm sorry about that it's my first time
ever using uh
discord so i'm a little i'm a noob so
um my degree is in news journalism um
i spent a few years as a journalist
before realizing that i could parlay my
i.t skills into something far more
profitable and now i regret it
okay and what i'm wondering is um
my fear is that the biggest
flaw in living in a democracy
is that we live in a democracy and we're
free to
disseminate disinformation and be
um just basically uh lie about what
what we want people to believe this is
that you have a socratic view of
democracy you're not so big on it
in many ways because of the problems
with it yeah
it so it's it's inherently uh open and
easily manipulated and
taken right and i think that the only
thing that's going to fix the problem
that we have
is the fact that we need to do something
about
right-wing media we need to
we need to basically get rid of fox news
oen newsmax breitbart
all the purveyors of lies and
misinformation that currently exists
but what i'm saying kind of sounds like
um stalinism
right i mean i was going to say what it
how do you do it you you make it illegal
to be
fox news i
have no clue how to go forward what i do
know is that our
we wouldn't be in the dire circumstances
that we're currently in
if it wasn't for the fact that all of
these
people have an echo chamber in which to
retreat where they can deny
reality and pretend that their way is
the righteous way
i want to short circuit going too far
down the road of eliminating it because
i just think it's the wrong path i think
it's too authoritarian for me and it's
too authoritarian for the united states
we need to properly fund education we
need to properly fund
public media look at you know look at
how bbc for example is funded
um in in the uk you need to
have some accountability for the impact
of deliberate
uh reporting of false news but it's too
authoritarian to say we're gonna figure
out some way to make fox news illegal
it'll bubble up in some other way
it's not the way that that things work
in the united states so
i think that uh there's a different
there's a different approach
that leads me to the the crux of my
argument in that once upon a time
we had the fcc's fairness doctrine yeah
that did
to a degree regulate news coverage yep
and i don't understand why we as an
american democratic open society
were able to control it once upon a time
and now can't other than the advent of
the internet i got a call well that's
exactly it i got a call about this a few
days ago and i think that at this point
just pushing for reinstating the
fairness doctrine
because the regulatory uh apparatus of
the fairness doctrine is for
the airwaves so to speak under the the
sort of paradigm of the
telecommunications act
and with so much of the news that we now
consume happening on the
on the internet and things that don't
even look or sound like what the
fairness doctrine
regulated um i don't think i also don't
think that's the path forward i just
don't think that it would um
i don't think that it would achieve what
you and i want to have achieved
which is a more informed population that
is not
susceptible to this fake news and
uh you know the i'm trying to remember
there's this thing about 1984
versus brave new world and you know the
the
the world described by brave new world
is one where
there's no need to censor or control
information because
um no oh i forget the quote but the
point is
we want a situation where it doesn't
matter that fox news exists because
people are smart enough to know it's
garbage and don't pay attention to it
um you're you're an optimist and
i am very much on the pessimistic end of
the scale because all i've seen during
my life span
is a slide towards the right and i don't
see anything impeding the slide
as it continues further to the right
right okay
fair fair dave i'm gonna let you go
because donald trump just published a
video okay
so that that's gonna do it for calls for
now the president is back on twitter
and has published a video let's take a
look this is a new statement from trump
now
unbanned on twitter i would like to
begin by addressing the heinous attack
on the united states capital like all
americans i am out
capital i like that raged by the
violence
lawlessness and mayhem i immediately
deployed the national guard
it's apparently that's not true and
apparently he didn't want to and it was
pence who deployed
and federal law enforcement to secure
the building
and expel the intruders america
is and must always be a nation of law
and order the demonstrators who
infiltrated the capital
have defiled the seat of american
democracy
to those who engaged in the acts of
violence and destruction
you do not represent our country and to
those
well they're acting in representation of
trump actually not the country
who broke the law you will pay we have
just been through an intense election
and emotions are high but now tempers
must be cooled
and calm restored we must get on
with the business of america my campaign
vigorously pursued every legal avenue
to contest the election this is
important he seems to be telling them to
simmer down
results my only goal was to ensure the
integrity of the vote
in so doing i was fighting to defend
american democracy
i continue to strongly believe that we
must reform our
election laws to verify the identity and
eligibility of all voters and to ensure
faith and confidence in all future
elections
now congress has certified the results a
new administration will be inaugurated
on january 20th
my focus now turns to ensuring a smooth
orderly insurance wow
this is for his legacy someone got to
him someone finally got to him
transition of power this moment calls
for
healing and reconciliation wow 2020 has
been a challenging time for our people
a menacing pandemic has upended the
lives of our citizens
isolated millions in their homes damaged
our economy
and claimed countless lives defeating
this pandemic and rebuilding the
greatest economy on earth
will require all of us working together
it will require a renewed emphasis on
the civic values of patriotism
faith hard to believe it's even a real
video charity community and family
we must revitalize the sacred bonds of
love and loyalty
that bind us together as one national
family
to the citizens of our country serving
as your president has been
the honor of my life wow and to all of
my wonderful supporters
i know you are disappointed but i also
want you to know
that our incredible journey is only
just beginning thank you god bless you
and god bless america wow um
this is this is amazing donald
trump figured out with 13 days left of
his
presidency how to
sound insincerely of course
presidential for two minutes
and 41 seconds
uh stunning stunning stuff it's
truly truly an incredible situation
hey here's our friendly ann caldwell
i've known her for over a decade she was
involved with some of the public radio
stuff that i was involved when uh
involved in earlier all right guys
that's gonna do it for me
i appreciate you joining me i appreciate
everybody who uh
was here the calls the subs everybody
who who contributed very much appreciate
it
um we'll be back very soon make sure
you're subscribed free on youtube make
sure you're following on twitch make
sure you've liked
on facebook and i'll see everybody again
very soon